Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW. Unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Brittlaf, hallo. Herzlich willkommen. Es ist irgendein Tag gerade. Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr. Ich bin schon wieder so in so einem ähm Corona,
Isolationsmodus, dass ich das mit den Wochentagen nicht mehr drauf habe. Ist ein.
Mittwoch.
Genau, ein Mittwoch. Ähm genauer der sechsundzwanzigste Januar zweiundzwanzig und ja ähm
ihr merkt schon, heute ist mal wieder ein Corona-Wickel dran, was jetzt natürlich nicht ganz so Vicky äh ist, aber ist auch egal, was.
Hat Zeit überhaupt noch für eine Bedeutung in diesen Zeiten? Hallo Pavel erstmal.
Hallo Tim.
Genau und ähm wir haben vor knapp drei Wochen zu euch gesprochen nachdem dieser ganze Weihnachtsaufregung durch war und so ein bisschen,
vor der fünften Welle vor der OmiCronnwelle. Haben so ein bisschen nach nach vorne geschaut, was uns denn,
was wir denn so denken, was jetzt so vielleicht,
könnte und um's vorwegzunehmen, wir haben natürlich mit allem total Recht gehabt, wie immer.
Ja okay, ganz so einfach. Ist jetzt auch nicht. Darüber wollen wir natürlich jetzt nochmal ähm sprechen,
Heute, weil es ja einiges ähm passiert ist und es gibt auch glaube ich so einige.
Wie soll ich sagen, Änderungen in der Debatte insgesamt, weltweit, aber auch in in Deutschland, ja.
Und ist die Frage, wie machen wir das am besten? Ich würde sagen, wir schauen uns vielleicht dann doch erst mal wie gewohnt.
So das Zahlenmaterial an. Gucken wir, was eigentlich so ähm.
Passiert ist und dann gucken wir noch mal, was so Neues gibt rund um Impfstoffe und und Onicron und wie die Lage vor allem einzuschätzen ist. Pavillon.
Das Zahlenwerk so her.
Ja, ich meine, die Zahlen mussten wir natürlich im Moment mal mit einer gewissen Vorsicht äh genießen, weil ja äh Testknappheit und so kommen wir später noch äh zu.
Aber so orientierungsmäßig ähm ja haben wir jetzt eine Tausende Inzidenz in Deutschland
nach Publikations äh Datum äh also tausend,
von hunderttausend in den letzten äh sieben Tagen haben sich,
infiziert und äh ja tausend von hunderttausend ist ein Prozent äh würde ich jetzt mal äh.
Mindestens ein Prozent.
Mhm.
Genau. Das kommt nämlich auch noch dazu. Äh ja, dass man wahrscheinlich nochmal jetzt im Moment Faktor zwei, drei, vielleicht sogar vier oben äh drauf äh rechnen muss äh auf
diese Inzidenzzahlen, um auf die wahren äh Inzidenzen zu kommen.
Und äh ja äh und es geht auch nach wie vor steil bergauf mit einem Sieben-Tage-R-Wert von 1,drei. Das ist so ja ähm,
im im Vergleich das ist so ja das Maximum dessen, was immer mal wieder erreicht worden
im Laufe der Pandemie in früheren Zeiten. Also es ist jetzt kein neuer R-Wert Rekord oder sieben Tage Albert-Rekord, da hatten wir,
ähm im Oktober zwanzig20 nochmal.
Äh mehr Ende Oktober genau, aber äh ja das erfreuliche daran ist, dass die,
Zahl der Todesfälle jetzt,
äh seit über einem Monat im Sinken begriffen ist. Ich glaube nicht, dass das so bleiben wird äh
aber ähm so im Moment äh jedenfalls sieht es
alles noch äh ganz gut aus dort. Wenn man denn äh von Jahrtausend,
45 Toten in den letzten sieben Tagen als Gutreden
äh kann, aber es sind halt eben deutlich weniger. Es hat sich fast halbiert äh oder mehr als halbiert sogar in den letzten drei Wochen.
Bei
Aber äh jetzt viel, viel höheren Inzidenzen, aber da muss man jetzt abwarten, weil das läuft halt natürlich immer so drei bis vier Wochen hinterher äh hinter den Inzidenzen.
Ähm weshalb ich
sie jetzt zumindest in anderen Ländern sah das dann so aus dass es nicht notwendigerweise zum Anstieg bei den Todesfällen gekommen ist oder nur zu einem leichten Anstieg aber eben die nicht bis auf null äh äh zurückgegangen sind,
so das kann man vielleicht jetzt äh zu den äh.
Deutschland weiten Zahlen sagen nach Altersgruppen ähm die Inzidenzen äh haben wir jetzt.
Weiter bei den fünf bis 14-jährigen einen Rekord von zweitausendsechshundert äh jetzt
dann äh die zweite Alters äh Gruppe oder die mit dem zweithöchsten äh Inzidenzwerten sind die 15 bis
Dreiunddreißigjährigen äh so mit äh ja tausendvierhundert Herr Inzidenzen. Und glücklicherweise äh sind die Inzidenzen in den
äh Altersgruppen ab 60. So bewegen sich noch im Bereich zwischen
ja 219 beziehungsweise 247 für die 60 bis 79-jährigen, aber äh sie steigen halt auch, wenn auch nicht nicht ganz äh so stark wie in den
anderen Altersgruppen und äh ja das ist sicherlich positiv äh.
Zu bewerten wird aber auch im Endeffekt dann wahrscheinlich auch wieder zu einem Anstieg äh bei den Toten,
führen. So.
Insbesondere weil halt in diesen Altersgruppen wie eigentlich in allen Altersgruppen bei den Impfungen jetzt nicht wirklich Fortschritte gemacht werden. Also sicherlich wird hier und da nach geboostert. Das hilft auch
aber erst im Funk Zweitimpfung das Problem der Leute, die halt überhaupt nicht geimpft sind, bleibt natürlich nach wie vor bestehen.
Ähm ja, wobei ähm ich meine, da kommen wir später noch noch zu.
Durchaus auch Hoffnung besteht in in mehreren Bereichen, dass dass
ja sich alles besser entwickelt als es im Moment aussieht aber äh sicher sein äh können wir uns nicht.
Besser entwickelt in Bezug auf die Impfung oder besser entwickelt in Bezug auf die schweren Fälle.
Die Folgen, auf die schweren Fälle, die Hospitalisierung und äh ja.
Ja, aber wenn etwas dazu beiträgt, dann ist es halt eher omikron. Als das die Leute sich besser schützen. Das wollte ich damit sagen.
Also nein nicht nicht nur äh sondern auch noch eventuell verbesserte Behandlungsmöglichkeiten. Das ist ja auch noch so ein.
Dann demnächst auch noch mit ins Spiel. In dem Moment, wo die wo Pax Louvied,
verfügbar ist, aber das ist meines Wissens noch nicht verfügbar.
Ähm ja vielleicht ein Blick noch in die Bundesländer, da haben wir einen eher ungewöhnliches
Bild im Moment, weil die
Länder, die wir sonst immer so eher in der Spitzengruppe gefunden haben, nämlich Sachsen-Anhalt, Sachsen und Thüringen
sind jetzt grade am Ende der Inzidenztabelle, also Thüringen mit 343 und Sachsen-Anhalt mit 515 wären ja die Tabelle von
Berlin, Hamburg und Bremen angeführt und ähm ja.
Bei weitem.
Ja bei bei weitem, genau. Also äh Berlin jetzt mit einer tausend ähneunhunderter Inzidenz
Nach äh ja Publikationsdatum äh und ja Hamburg tausendsiebenhundert Bremen tausendsechshundertzweiundvierzig.
Und wahrscheinlich ist es aber äh wie gesagt ein Vielfaches davon. So, das heißt
man kann jetzt sagen, dass in Berlin wahrscheinlich, wenn man jetzt mal konservativ rechnet, äh tausend
neunhundert, von hunderttausend ähm sind eins Komma neun Prozent mal zweieinhalb, die haben wir mindestens, das heißt 5 Prozent der Berliner haben sich in den letzten sieben Tagen wahrscheinlich
mit Coronainfizieren.
Ja vielleicht mehr und das ist.
Das ist das ist schon mal eine eine Hausnummer. Das ist schon mal eine.
Was lesen wir da jetzt raus? Wir lesen da jetzt nicht unbedingt raus, dass jetzt in Sachsen und in äh Sachsen-Anhalt alle sich auf einmal impfen und ganz vorsichtig sind, sondern hier haben wir es wahrscheinlich schlicht und ergreifend mit einer anderen Verteilung von,
zu tun. Während halt die nördlichen Stadtstaaten,
sehr viel näher an den potenziellen Importgebieten, sprich Dänemark, Yarlande äh et cetera. Dran sind einerseits aber andererseits natürlich die Stadtstaaten,
eine ganz andere.
Besuchsquote haben, ne, also ein ganz anderer Austauschquote haben mit dem ähm mit dem Ausland oder überhaupt anderen äh Städten.
Ähm das zeigt sich hier glaube ich, dass wir also einfach über diese Importe in größeren Mengen um Mikron bekommen haben und dazu kommt natürlich auch noch, dass die Stadt halt.
Den Vorteil hat, ne, also wir sehen halt einfach um Mikron ist super infektiös, das heißt, wenn's halt hier erstmal in der U-Bahn ist, dann dann geht's halt auch irgendwie rum.
Und dementsprechend überrascht mich das nicht. Ich genauso wenig wäre ich überrascht, wenn dann halt bei Hamburg sieht man jetzt schon so einen Knick bei den Inzidenzen. Der mag jetzt noch nicht.
Ein Trend ankündigen, aber ich wäre jetzt auch nicht überrascht, wenn halt Berlin,
Hamburg und Bremen auch die Ersten sind, die dann äh irgendwann so
signifikanten Trend nach unten zeigen. Das ist noch ein bisschen hin, aber sicherlich früher als die anderen, so dass man davon ausgehen kann, dass halt die Flächenländer und insbesondere die Länder.
Die jetzt vielleicht nicht so viel Tourismus und sonstigen Austausch äh haben ähm.
Deren richtige Omikron-Welle eigentlich noch bevorsteht.
Wahrscheinlich ja äh da mal später auch noch etwas konkretere äh äh Zahlen zu.
Und ja die R-Werte sind aber in allen äh Bundesländern über
eins äh im Moment, aber äh eben jetzt da sind jetzt Schleswig-Holstein, Bremen und Hamburg
ähm sagen, haben jetzt die niedrigsten Steigerungs äh raten äh zu verzeichnen gerade. Ja während.
Der Rest aufholt.
Saarland ist recht weit oben und Brandenburg auch gut dabei. Ja, Bayern, Sachsen-Anhalt.
Was im Prinzip meine These jetzt schon auch schon ein bisschen vielleicht nicht bestätigt, aber unterstützt, dass halt die Stadtstaaten.
An.
Anfangen, sozusagen die Dynamik wieder ein bisschen rauszunehmen während die anderen halt eigentlich erst richtig loslegen.
Ja, deswegen lohnt sich halt jetzt auch noch mal ein bisschen äh tieferer Blick äh.
Ähm auf Berlin äh wie es wie es da aussieht und ähm.
Ja äh Inzidenzen.
Ja offiziell 1900. Mhm aber die Zahl der,
Toten ist jetzt seit Wochen hm unverändert, ja.
Ähm wie gesagt, das kann sein, dass es da oder wird wahrscheinlich da jetzt auch zu einem leichten Anstieg kommen, aber zumindest bei den Toten ist noch kein
Anstieg derzeit zu bemerken. Ja ähm und wo.
Gut nach und nach Altersgruppen ähm ja haben wir eine 4tausend900er Inzidenz bei den äh fünf bis 14jährigen in Berlin.
Das ist das wäre früher natürlich äh sagen, oh mein Gott, fünftausender Inzidenz, so was haben wir gar nicht
vorher nie gesehen und wenn man sich dann die Kurve jetzt auch anguckt mit von Anfang der Pandemie, dann sieht man die ganzen Wellen gar nicht mehr, dann sieht man äh halt noch
Eine Welle vorher so äh bei den bei den äh5 bis bis 14-jährigen in Berlin und äh ja dann jetzt die Explosion und
alle anderen ähm Inzidenzen fast äh ja.
Also man kann einfach festhalten, es rauscht durch die Schulen.
Zwar in hohem Maße und wenn man vor allem mal den eben schon angenommenen Dunkel äh Ziffer Faktor zwei Komma fünf hier ansetzen, ja, dann dann sind wir halt bei zwölf, zwölfeinhalb Prozent.
Aller 5- bis 14-jährigen in einer Woche.
So also das ne und und und das ist halt auch sagen wir mal das Untere was man annehmen kann. Wenn wir gleich sehen werden wir auf die Positiv-Quote gucken also
Da ist dann auch irgendwann nicht mehr viel zu holen. Hier zeichnet sich einfach ganz klar ab, was man schon eigentlich Anfang des Jahres
gesehen hat, nämlich it's coming and we can't stop it. So also wir können das zumindest nicht wir reden vielleicht gleich nochmal über die Maßnahmen, die man jetzt eingreifen kann oder äh nicht nicht kann.
Aber es ist ähm kaum einzufangen. Ja zumindest wird es nicht eingefangen, sagen wir's mal so.
Ja. Ja die Auslastung der Intensivstationen in Berlin wird mit 18 Prozent gemeldet.
Ähm was irgendwie die Ampel,
gelb leuchten lässt, also bei 20Prozent würde sie auf rot gehen. Also insofern ist die Situation zumindest
Ampeltechnisch irgendwie im gelben Bereich grade äh in Berlin und hm.
Was wir jetzt ja auch schon angesprochen hatten, ist das Thema Variantenverteilung. Und da gibt es auch oft
der Seite vom LAGSO, die die auch kontinuierlich ganz gut weiterentwickelt haben, muss ich sagen. Das ist jeden Fall was Positives. Da gibt's jetzt dann auch Grafen zum Beispiel zur Variantenverteilung in,
Berlin, nach Labordaten und,
Demnach sind wir jetzt bei äh mindestens 97 Prozent um Mikron Anteil in Berlin. Und äh ja.
Und ansonsten die drei Prozent äh sind Delta äh noch. So. Aber das ist,
nicht, was man bundesweit sieht, sondern wir haben dann auch noch bei den Zahlen vom Bund sind wir erst bei 62,4 Prozent am OmiCon.
Und noch immer bei siebenunddreißig Prozent Delta, siebenunddreißig Komma vier Prozent.
Was halt bedeutet, wenn es in Berlin eben bei 97 Prozent ist und in einigen anderen Gegenden,
auch äh kann man jetzt mal davon
ausgehen, äh heißt es, dass es eben in ländlichen Regionen oder in Regionen, wo noch nicht, äh wo es noch nicht so richtig losgegangen ist.
Ähm dass dort äh ja noch zur Hälfte ähm oder mehr vielleicht äh Delta äh noch unterwegs ist so.
Was dann halt auch noch die Todeszahlen sozusagen auch noch mit füttert.
Ja, was zum einen vielleicht die Todeszahlen mit äh füttert, so. Ähm,
aber äh vor allen Dingen ähm in diesen Gegenden auch noch zu der blöden Situation führen kann, dass man äh sich äh jetzt noch Delta holt, ja, das Auslaufmodell,
äh dann äh wenn man Pech hat äh da gab's jetzt einen Fall, äh hat dann äh jemand einen einen Schüler so sechs Wochen später sich die andere Variante geholt, ja und auch nochmal
ähm so und das will man glaube ich auch nicht haben, ja.
So und deswegen ist es halt in den Gegenden ja mal ja ähm besonders äh unschön gerade mit den mit den,
ähm Inzidenzen. Mit den hohen.
Ja, aber das aber das zeigt auch hier wieder, also ich gewinne in zunehmenden Maße so diese Sicht, dass dass Berlin jetzt so quasi so ein bisschen der Blick in die Zukunft ist.
Also ist es ja sowieso, ne? Ähm,
für die pandemische Situation in Deutschland. Also das jetzt eigentlich, genauso wie eben die anderen Stadtstaaten, ne? Omikron ist hier voll reingekommen, verdrängt Delta.
Ja, das war ja auch lange Zeit so eine offene Frage, ja, also.
Nur ein bisschen weniger kann's irgendwie koexistieren, aber ist relativ klar. Delta hat einfach in Anbetracht der Präsenz von Omicron irgendwie keine Chance.
Und verschwindet so. Aber es ist halt noch nicht überall so weit, sondern man muss wahrscheinlich davon ausgehen, dass es jetzt so in Sachsen und Thüringen.
Kann ich mir jetzt nur so ein bisschen aus dem Bauch heraus ableiten. In zwei Wochen soweit sein wird, dass wir so eine ähnliche Situation haben wie jetzt in Berlin.
Ähm was äh jetzt auch noch mal an dieser Stelle schon mal, weil wir werden,
zum Schluss sicherlich nochmal die Generaldebatte äh äh machen so den den ja den Elefanten im,
im Raum äh äh äh natürlich ausgiebig äh würdigen, nämlich die Frage, so ähm geben wir alles frei oder ähm,
wie lange müssen wie lange passen wir noch auf? Müssen wir so oder wie lange soll das noch so weitergehen äh wie bisher äh so und ähm,
aus diesen Zahlen äh,
jetzt also gerade aus den Variantenzahlen kann man sehen, vor allen Dingen aus den absoluten Zahlen äh jetzt vom vom LAGSO sieht man, dass Delta äh.
Stark zurückgeht, also auch in absoluten Zahlen, weil wir ja sagen, okay, die Inzidenzen explodieren jetzt und vielleicht ist ja ähm Delta.
Auf einem bleibt auf dem Niveau und Omikron schießt nur in die Höhe und deswegen äh ändert sich der Prozentsatz, aber nein, es ist tatsächlich so, äh dass die Zahl der Delta-Fälle
in absoluten äh absolut gemessen äh auch auf vielleicht weiß ich nicht drei äh fünf fünf sechs Prozent,
zurückgegangen ist von dem was es jetzt noch im Dezember war also,
und das relativ früh im Jahr, im im im Winter, das heißt wir haben,
wie auch immer äh haben wir halt Delta nieder,
sehr wahrscheinlich äh zum großen Teil durch durch Impfungen.
So ähm und durch die durch die Maßnahmen haben wir es äh ja jedenfalls geschafft jetzt Delta einzudämmen.
Aber noch nicht ganz. Also wie gesagt es ist es ist noch Delta unterwegs und eigentlich sollten wir
vielleicht gucken ja dass wir dieses dieses Delta auch vielleicht ganz wegkriegen ja wäre ja nicht nicht verkehrt
so wenn das wenn das irgendwie gelingen könnte.
Ähm ob das klappt, äh weiß ich nicht, aber ich ich finde, wenn man noch drei Prozent hat, sollte man jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen, okay
wir wir geben jetzt alles komplett frei und lassen jetzt laufen und am Ende kriegen wir jetzt dann noch vielleicht eine neue Delta-Welle oder so.
Mit dem mit dem Angriff von Omicron wird das alles.
Angriff OmiCon, äh das alles richten, ja. Genau. Ähm ja, hm.
Aber äh da kommt man dann später noch zu, aber das ist hier jedenfalls ein ein Punkt äh äh gerade. Ähm dass wir gerade erfolgreich äh Delta äh bekämpfen und bekämpft.
Haben und vermutlich im Wesentlichen durch Impfungen. So um das vielleicht einfach noch mal im Hinterkopf behalten. An dieser Stelle.
So sind wir schon durch. Nee, jetzt haben wir noch unsere äh.
Die Tests.
Tests genau.
Die Positiv-Quote ähm.
Ja, also zum einen haben wir jetzt eine Rekordpositiv-Quote erreicht.
Mal wieder von.
24,42 Prozent. So, also ungefähr jeder vierte PCA-Test, der im Moment gemacht wird, ist positiv.
Es wurde auch eine Rekordzahl von Tests ähm erstmals etwas über zwei Millionen, zwei Millionen, 50.000 Tests wurden durchgeführt.
Und das führt dann halt äh zu ja dieser Rekordmenge von einer halben Million positiver Tests äh in,
der Kalenderwoche äh so stand ähm zwanzigste erste. Also in der zweiten Kalenderwoche.
Ja, neu äh ganz viele Tests und trotzdem steigt die Positiv-Quote, ne. Also hatten wir letzte Woche schon den ähm.
Rekord beziehungsweise vor zwei Wochen war auch schon Rekord, also ist jetzt Dauerrekord, vierundzwanzig Komma vier zwei.
Alter Falter, das ist wirklich richtig viel.
Ja und wie gesagt, halbe Million positiver Tests. Also wir hatten viele Zeiten, da gab's irgendwie nicht mal, wurden nicht mal eine halbe Million Tests gemacht ähm so, also im.
Letzten Sommer hatten wir ja so sechshunderttausend Tests pro Woche und jetzt haben wir 500.000 positive Tests.
Pro Woche. Wobei äh ja Testknappheit, wobei,
offiziell gibt es keinen Probenrückstau oder die Probenrückstaumeldung beim RKI funktioniert,
nicht oder niemand macht sich Mühe da irgendwas einzutragen. Also laut RKI gibt es aber keinen Probenrückstau und die Kapazität ist noch geringfügig höher ähm,
so als äh ja die Zahl der durchgeführten Tests, aber,
Aber regional habe ich gehört äh gibt es eben schon 100 Prozent Auslastung und äh dann,
gibt es halt auch ein Proben-Rückstau, aber wie groß der ist äh ist halt unklar.
Aber im Moment will's auch niemand mehr so genau wissen, habe ich das Gefühl. So,
also Leute schon erzählt, dass sie sich also wahrscheinlich auch lieber,
ähm dann privat erstmal testen werden und eigentlich lieber sich aus der offiziellen Testmaschinerie raushalten wollen, weil dann äh keine Ahnung
Quarantäne oder andere Maßnahmen drohen. Also das Ganze das ist halt die reinste Anarchie mittlerweile und die Gesundheitsämter haben ja auch die Kontaktrückverfolgung massiv zurückgefahren und
ähm ja Anarchie. Ja dann.
Auch nochmal jetzt,
Blick auf die Hospitalisierungen so in Deutschland, da gibt's jetzt verschiedene noch Hochberechnungen. Einmal gibt's halt den Now Cast vom,
RKI, der versucht, die vorherzusagen und dann gibt's irgendwie noch äh ja eine Ampel
Berechnung äh dazu und da sieht es so aus im Moment deutschlandweit
zeigt halt die Ampelhochrechnung jetzt eine steigende Zahl an Hospitalisierungen
mittlerweile wieder an, während äh ja des RKI Nowcast
äh im Moment äh noch nicht angeschlagen äh hat.
Jetzt mal eine Frage, weil also das ist ja etwas, was jetzt gerade in der OmiCronn-Welle auch nochmal international sehr,
fein auseinandergehalten wird und ich glaube, wir haben da in Deutschland immer nur so ein eine Seite der Medaille, weil es wird halt jetzt generell geschaut einerseits auf,
Krankenhaus, Einweisung, also die sogenannten Hospital Atmissions ja und dann eben die Belegung.
Ich glaube, wir haben bisher in Deutschland immer nur von der Belegung gesprochen, wie viele Leute sind denn gerade im Krankenhaus mit covid beziehungsweise wie viel Leute sind denn gerade auf Intensivstationen mit Covid? Das war bisher immer so der
das, was man sich angeschaut hat, weil man irgendwie wusste, na wenn man erstmal im Krankenhaus ist, dann dann dann bleibt man da auch eine Weile. Mit Omicron hat sich das jetzt ein bisschen geändert und das hat sich ja schon relativ früh in Südafrika abgezeichnet.
Halt vorher die Leute so im Schnitt zehn Tage auf dem Krankenhaus waren und dann halt entweder entlassen wurden oder gestorben äh sind.
Ging ja diese Zahl der Aufenthaltsdauer enorm runter. Also ich glaube, das war in Südafrika relativ früh, dass sich das so auf zwei, drei Tage eingependelt hat und wenn man jetzt auf Data schaut, wird eben für manche Länder,
beides ausgespuckt.
Ich glaube zum Beispiel so Hospital Editions, also nur so wie viele neue Leute sind ins Krankenhaus grade aufgenommen worden. Ist eine Zahl, die wir so in Deutschland gar nicht haben.
Also wenn wir jetzt hier von Hospitalisierungen sprechen, reden wir von Leuten im Krankenhaus mit Covid.
Ja, die werden auch, die werden wöchentlich werden die halt erhoben äh äh die Zahlen äh beziehungsweise.
Also es gibt gibt da verschiedene Erhebungen schon äh zu ähm aber eben auch immer zeitlich das das das dauert.
Ja, aber es ist eine kumulative Zahl, ne, sozusagen. Man sieht nicht, wie viel kommt dazu. Sondern nur so als Differenz und.
Nee, doch, doch, doch, doch. Es gibt also mittlerweile, es gibt halt schon auch Zahlen, wo man dann gucken kann und sagen, okay, von den
äh Infizierten äh wurden jetzt in dem selben Zeitraum dann äh so und so viel
dann ja ins Krankenhaus eingeliefert und von denen mussten dann so und so viel beatmet werden und von denen sind dann so und so viel gestorben und das gibt sogar auch für
sagen unterschiedlichen nach unterschiedlichen Impfstatus aufgeschlüsselt. Ich hab's jetzt noch nicht nach Varianten.
Geschlüsselt gesehen, was natürlich auch interessant wäre äh so, aber äh ja, so schnell äh äh sind wir äh soweit noch noch nicht in in in Deutschland äh außer dass es halt in,
Studien äh noch gemacht wird, aber ähm ja und wie gesagt.
Mitnehmen kann man dort äh ja ähm,
Die Zahl der der Hospitalisierungen, Leute, die jetzt ins Krankenhaus kommen, die absolute Zahl steigt an derzeit in äh Deutschland. So.
Hochgerechnet steigt sie an ähm ja während die Intensiv,
ähm so deren Belegung äh eher gesunken ist oder sich seitwärts bewegt.
Ja
Okay. Dann schauen wir mal so ein bisschen auch auf die internationale Situation.
Ja, das Problem ist und deswegen mache ich's auch gar nicht. Ähm ist, dass man derzeit die.
Inzidenzen in den verschiedenen Ländern noch weniger vergleichen kann als ähm.
Normalerweise äh äh schon,
in Europa äh sind eigentlich die Inzidenzen ja über neuntausend äh so.
Ähm wer jetzt vielleicht also nicht wirklich über neuntausend, aber äh sagen über neuntausend, gut der ein oder andere wird die Referenz
äh verstehen. Ähm sie sind halt so hoch, äh dass es sich kaum lohnt. Ähm
sie sich sie sich wirklich anzuschauen, ja. Also wir haben gut
Wir haben in einigen Ländern dann Inzidenzen von sechs, sieben, achttausend. Ja, das äh ähm.
Und ähm ja also es es geht jetzt rum einfach äh ja hm.
Und.
Mhm was man allerdings dann auch sieht jetzt in in den in Dänemark äh gerade bei den ganz hohen Inzidenzen, dass jetzt dann natürlich auch zwangsläufig, wenn sich jetzt plötzlich
innerhalb von einer Woche, ich sage mal 20 oder 30 Prozent der äh Jugendlichen,
infizieren ähm dann ähm ja äh sieht man natürlich auch die Zahl
der ähm Kinder und Jugendlichen, die dann Beschwerden haben oder auch äh keine leichten Verläufe und behandelt werden.
Müssen und sicherlich auch einen leichten Anstieg der Todesfälle wird man sehen, aber das äh bei Kindern, aber das ähm,
wird sich wahrscheinlich eher im einstelligen Bereich bewegen, vielleicht den zweistelligen Bereich. Ähm.
Ja für Deutschland hatte ich mal hochgerechnet schon vor einem Jahr oder so, was das bedeuten würde jetzt.
Mit damaligen Zahlen nicht nicht für OmiCron hätte das halt ähm,
sagen einmal durch infizieren bei den 0 bis Fünfjährigen äh ungefähr bis zu 50 ähähTote. Ähm.
Äh ja gekostet und äh also und,
nochmal zwischen im im Alter 5 bis zehn4 wahrscheinlich auch nochmal in der Größenordnung 50 bis 1hundert so. Wie es jetzt mit aussehen wird wissen wir nicht, aber muss sagen, es wird jetzt auch nicht völlig spurlos an den Kindern.
Vorbeigehen in so kurzer Zeit, ja, wenn sich ein Drittel oder die Hälfte von ihnen infizieren in innerhalb von wenigen Wochen.
Vielleicht um diese ganzen Zahlen.
Debatte nochmal kurz abzurunden. Es gab auf Hour World and Data eine interessante neue Grafik. Jetzt sind wir ja quasi so mit der Optik von den,
von Hour World and Data schon sehr vertraut. Ähm.
Trotzdem das Team wirft immer mal wieder interessante Vergleiche auf, was die mal jetzt gemacht haben, ist.
Sie haben sich die,
Verläufe von diesen vier Kerndaten sage ich jetzt mal, über die will ich auch die ganze Zeit reden, also Inzidenzfälle,
ja? Wie viele Patienten sind in auf den Intensivstationen? Wie viele Leute sind überhaupt ins Krankenhaus eingewiesen worden und ähm.
Totenzahlen. Diese vier hm Kurven.
Haben sie mal in eine einzige Grafik zusammengeführt und zum Zeitpunkt des Höhepunkts, der.
Welle also in Deutschland ungefähr so im Januar, also im Prinzip vor einem Jahr.
Haben Sie das sozusagen einfach mal als 100 Prozent markiert. Das heißt, obwohl jetzt diese Zahlen miteinander jetzt.
Absoluten Zahlen nichts miteinander zu tun haben und einfach mal diese Kurven quasi zu diesem Zeitpunkt Anfang des Jahres synchronisiert und uns gesagt, okay das ist jetzt,
hundert Prozent. Das ist so das ist jetzt so, das war so ein Höhepunkt, der Infektionswelle und da war dann auch ein Höhepunkt von Todeszahlen et cetera. Diese Peaks haben sie halt irgendwie alle übereinander gelegt.
Ja und was was sieht man dann? Man sieht halt, dass ähm.
Impfungen, eine Auswirkung hatten. Das heißt, die Wellen liegen so übereinander. Man kann halt sehen, so ah okay, eine Welle schlägt mehr aus, aber die anderen folgen nicht nach. Ne, also die Zahl der Toten gingen von äh Nachwelle zu Nachwelle immer weiter runter.
Und ähm jetzt
in der letzten Delta-Om-Mikron-Welle in Deutschland gehen halt die Cases einfach durch die Decke, aber der Rest will halt nicht so folgen. Das haben wir ja im Prinzip eben auch schon mal aus den Zahlen herausgelesen, aber da sieht man das sozusagen alles auf einen
Blick. Ich habe euch die Grafik und den Link natürlich auch nochmal in die Shownotes und die Bilder im Block gepackt.
Ja und das ist ähm so ein bisschen das, was sich derzeit aus diesen Zahlen summa summarum ablesen lässt. Also diese Aufregung um Fälle,
ne und diese Vergleichbarkeit ist nicht nur international nicht gegeben, sondern selbst wenn wir jetzt innerhalb von,
Deutschland jetzt zurückblicken von vor einem Jahr, was,
ne, Inzidenzen dort bedeutet haben, zu dem, was sie jetzt bedeutet, man muss das alles neu interpretieren. Muss das jetzt anders äh kontextualisieren, weil das Virus ist jetzt einfach ein anderes geworden. Glücklicherweise.
Ähm und.
Ja beziehungsweise das System Virusbevölkerung ist ein anderes äh äh geworden.
Genau, also wollte ich gerade sagen, also Impfungen kommen ja da sozusagen auch noch mit mit ins Spiel, aber unter anderem eben auch.
Omikron gerade jetzt mit seiner hohen Infektiösität hätte es die jetzt so nicht gegeben, würden ja die Wellen auch anders aussehen, ne. Aber sie werden dann vielleicht nicht mehr so dermaßen entkoppelt, wie sie's ähm jetzt eben zu sein scheinen.
Anlass genug, äh um jetzt noch mal so zusammenzufassen, okay, was wissen wir denn jetzt eigentlich über Omikrone oder was hat sich jetzt insbesondere in den letzten Wochen noch so Neues ergeben?
Wie gefährlich ist äh OmiCron eigentlich wirklich? Was hast du denn da für einen Einblick.
Ja ähm sagen erstmal mein Eindruck ist.
Dass sich zwar zum einen verfestigt das Omi-Cron jetzt wahrscheinlich ja äh oder offensichtlich weniger Probleme macht äh so
aber
so was jetzt die Gefährlichkeit äh angeht äh sage ich mal für wen? Insbesondere darüber, da scheiden sich noch so ein bisschen die
Geister äh so und auch mhm was jetzt die Infektiösität,
angeht, also wie ja wie schnell sich das das jetzt ausbreitet äh woran das jetzt liegt. Da scheint sich auch noch keine einheitliche Meinung zu gebildet zu haben.
Aber ähm,
ja ähm was ganz offensichtlich ist und deswegen sind wir jetzt auch durch die ganzen Zahlen äh durchgegangen, so.
OmiCon macht weniger Probleme äh in der aktuellen Welle ähm so pro Infizierten als ähm,
Ja wir das in den vergangenen Wellen gesehen haben und hm da gibt's jetzt,
verschiedene Vermutungen, äh warum das so ist so. Die eine Vermutung ist, dass Omikon an sich harmloser,
bis so. Das ist eine Variante ist die ich sage mal von sich aus weniger Probleme macht. Ähm,
andere These ist, dass sie nur deswegen weniger Probleme macht, weil hm.
Ja äh ein Großteil der Bevölkerung äh entweder geimpft oder halt vorher schon mit der anderen äh Variante.
Erkrankt war oder oder infiziert war und daher eine eine gewisse Immunität hat und dass wir deswegen äh diese ganzen ähm nicht nur diese ganzen,
harmloseren Verläufe sehen, sondern äh äh dass äh auch die These, dass der Verlauf äh äh oder dass die Ausbreitung die Infektiösität hm.
Auch gar nicht höher ist, sondern äh eben die Ausbreitung nur darauf zurückzuführen ist, dass ähm man für die Ausbreitung auch die ganzen bisher Geimpften
und äh Vorerkrankten zur Verfügung stehen. So ja also.
Alles so ein bisschen unübersichtlich äh vor allem wenn man dann noch dazu nimmt eben die Frage ja äh.
Wie gut bin ich denn jetzt geschützt eigentlich äh wenn ich jetzt geimpft bin
und ähm oder gar geboostert und wenn ich mich dann infiziere ähm so äh wie.
Ist dann der Schutz noch und das hatten wir ja auch,
in vergangenen Sendungen äh schon,
immer wieder behandelt und hm.
Ja äh da ist es so ähm dass die Zahlen die für den Schutz der,
beispielsweise ja von von den aktuellen Impfungen sagen vor Hospitalisierung da äh gibt es dann ähm eben einmal einen Prozentwert für den für den Schutz.
Ohne Ansteckung, also sozusagen den den Ansteckungsschutz, den ich durch Impfung habe, mal dem
schwere Verlaufsschutz so dass es die Zahl die normalerweise angegeben wird aber ähm die gilt halt nicht wenn ich mich erstmal
angesteckt habe und was wir halt wissen, ist, dass sich im Prinzip jeder anstecken äh kann. Also auch äh also mit OmiCon äh jetzt
bei den aktuellen
Impfungen äh ist es so, egal ob geboostert äh oder dreimal äh geimpft oder vorerkrankt und äh geimpft mit einer anderen äh äh Variante so äh im Prinzip äh
ja kann trotzdem jeder ja sich mit Omi-Kron infizieren.
Und wenn man sich dann aber erstmal infiziert hat, ist äh dieser Hospitalisierungs äh Schutz ähm
sagen nur noch was wäre halt ein Faktor drei. So insgesamt äh sagen der Schutz, wenn ich geimpft bin, sagen vor Ansteckung äh und Hospitalisierung,
ist halt bis zu neunzig oder über 90 Prozent, aber äh wie gesagt, wenn ich den
den Infektionsschutz wegnehme, dann bleibt nur noch irgendwie Faktor zwei bis drei an äh Hospitalisierungsschutz übrig für bereits äh Infizierte. So. Äh.
Was halt ähm.
Ja äh immer noch gut ist natürlich, also ein Drittel der schweren Verläufe äh.
Ist ein Drittel der schweren Verläufe, aber es ist immer noch ein Drittel von äh den schweren äh Verläufen so. Will sagen ähm.
Wenn ich mich nicht infiziere, bin ich.
Ganz sicher von einem schweren Verlauf geschützt natürlich, weil ich gar keinen Verlauf habe so. Insofern ähm ja ähm so ist die Frage.
Stellt sich die Frage, lässt sich äh vielleicht dann doch eine Omikon äh Infektion jetzt vermeiden?
Und äh ich sehe da durchaus eine gewisse Chance so
Also es muss nicht jeden erwischen. So, nicht ausnahmslos jeden.
Und man müsste jetzt eigentlich ja nur bis, ich weiß nicht März oder April durchhalten und vielleicht eben die Wellen dann ja auch schon ab. Das heißt, es gäbe durchaus eine gewisse Chance, jetzt auch
ohne OmiCroninfektion äh an den Punkt zu kommen, wo es dann eben auch einen äh äh omikron Impfstoff gibt,
und äh das wäre dann für mich dann auch so die die Stelle, wo es dann wahrscheinlich für mich dann auch mehr oder weniger sich erledigt hätte mit der im Frei, jedenfalls bis auf auf Weiteres, aber ich sage mal
Ähm diese sagen diese Option oder diese Alternative also vielleicht durchzukommen äh so.
Keine völlig
unrealistische würde ich einfach mal sagen oder zumindest ähm mal sollte man aus meiner Sicht nicht unbedingt die Nähe des äh Viruses suchen, wenn man nicht unbedingt.
Das hast du jetzt aber sehr nordmäßig und einem sehr langen Satz.
Noch mal in einem ganz kurzen Satz zusammen.
Ähm ja.
Es ist sinnvoller sich nicht zu infizieren, dann ist die Chance nicht ins Krankenhaus zu kommen, einfach äh noch größer.
Im Mikronähr äh äh milder ist. Ja, das kann man das Wort kann man jetzt glaube ich mal sagen, ja.
Milder ist kein Omikron und von daher äh sind persönliche Schutzmaßnahmen nach wie vor angemessen. Es ist halt nur so, man muss sie jetzt sehr viel strikter einhalten.
Sonst erwischt einen das halt. Also so was vielleicht vor zwei Jahren noch super funktioniert hat so mit ab und zu mal eine Maske auf und wie so und so lange kannst du dich vielleicht auch im Raum noch mit der halbwegs gut gelüftet ist mit Leuten aufhalten ähm.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, sich das da nicht einzufangen, das Virus, wenn es im Raum ist, die äh sinken dann doch erheblich. Das heißt, jetzt funktioniert es nur mit einer gut sitzenden FFP2-Maske.
Ne und auch dann hast du natürlich noch ein Restrisiko so. Das scheint sehr viel zu helfen, aber na ja.
Ja. So auf der anderen Seite.
Ich sage mal als jetzt jüngerer und Geimpfter Mensch ähm so klar Risiko besteht immer, aber ähm.
Das ist sozusagen die andere Seite der der Medaille gerade ähm ja wenn man jung und geimpft oder vielleicht sogar dann auch noch geboostert,
ist so,
würde ich wahrscheinlich ja mich mich jetzt nicht von so vielem abhalten lassen, was ich gerne tun würde, so würde ich's mal ausdrücken.
Ja gut, zu der Debatte kommen wir ja jetzt eh gleich nochmal, was denn ähm jetzt so die Maßnahmen sind oder was was äh passieren wird. Vielleicht noch mal so ein bisschen als Nachtrag. Also es ist halt einfach klar ähm.
Omicon sorgt trotz höherer Infektion für weniger Probleme. Dadurch, dass wir viele Infektionen haben, gehen die Zahlen immer noch hoch und man muss immer noch befürchten, dass es eine.
Überlastung des medizinischen Systems gibt.
Nur ist sie nicht ausschließlich durch durch jetzt ähm die Belegung der Intensivstation oder die Belegung der Krankenhäuser selber äh,
verursacht, sondern eben auch dadurch, dass jetzt einfach so viele Leute einfach auch mal krank werden.
Auch vom medizinischen Personal, dass halt auch deren Kapazitäten ähm davon betroffen sind und das haben wir ja nicht nur dort, das haben wir bei der Feuerwehr, haben wir bei der Polizei einfach.
Überall. Das ist jetzt sozusagen nochmal so so ein kritischer Moment. Nichtsdestotrotz ist ähm OmiCronn selbst erst mal nicht so.
Gefährlich und das weiß man ja mittlerweile auch. Wir hatten das ja hier schon.
Äh letzte Mal glaube ich schon angesprochen letzte Mal oder war's vorletztes Mal? Weiß nicht mehr so ganz genau die Erkenntnisse warum denn das so ist und das scheint sich jetzt auch zu.
Bestätigen oder zumindest zu erhärten. Habe jetzt nichts gesehen, was in eine andere Richtung geht, also um's noch mal zusammenzufassen. Omi Coint ist deshalb nicht so gefährlich wie Delta,
Weil vor allem nicht nur, ja, aber vor allem.
Weil es sich so angepasst hat, dass es sich eben in den oberen Luftwegen schnell.
Einnistet und dann dort auch sehr viel schneller repliziert und dann eben auch von dort schneller wieder ausm Körper rausgeben kann. Das heißt, das ist quasi die Optimierung, die das Virus vorgenommen hat in dieser Variante. Es kann schneller.
Die Bronchien, Rachen Bereich ähm den schneller befallen, dort schneller replizieren und schneller und ist dann natürlich auch schneller wieder draußen.
Es verzichtet sozusagen äh auf diesen Umweg Lunge.
Weil die Lunge ist eigentlich gar nicht so hilfreich, ja da klar das Husten, was dann eingesetzt äh.
Das hat dann auch dazu beigetragen, dass die Leute.
Das Virus wieder ausgespielen haben, aber da funktioniert Niesen sehr viel besser ja. Das war schon immer so die Optimierung der Erkältung. Warum niesen die Leute? Es,
die totale Beschleunigungsrampe für das Virus und es muss irgendwie gar nicht so tief rein.
Das Gute für uns alle ist halt da dran, das bedeutet, dass eben die Lunge nicht mehr so belastet wird. Das bedeutet, dass
das Risiko schwerer Verläufe, das Risiko von Longdrovid, weil es einfach nicht mehr so leicht ins Blut übergehen äh kann über die Lungenbläschen
und eben auch die Probleme, die ganze Verklebungen, die ganze Zellzerstörung, die es in den Lungen ähm angerichtet hat, weswegen wir so viele
künstliche Bar Atmung gesehen haben oder Beatmungshilfen gesehen haben. All das ist reduziert. Es ist nicht komplett ausgeschlossen, ne und.
Viele Leute haben auch immer noch ein Problem damit, aber es ist halt, es spielt sich mittlerweile auf einen ähm auf einem anderen Level. Äh.
Was man jetzt auch noch herausgefunden hat äh oder meint herausgefunden zu haben, so will ich das mal ausdrücken.
Ist das äh offenbar auch die Art, wie das Virus in die Zelle eindringt, sich noch mal.
Geändert hat. Also wir kennen ja sozusagen dieses klassische Bild, das Virus kommt an, Doktor an seinen ACE äh Rezepte ein und und dann wird das sozusagen so direkt über die Zellmembranen reingezogen.
Schon tausend Videos gesehen. Hat jeder irgendwie so ein Bild äh im Kopf. Es gibt aber noch einen zweiten,
Weg oder diese Endlosomen, wo das Virus sozusagen nochmal so in so eine in eine Hülle gepackt wird und dann mit Hülle eintritt und dann quasi von innen heraus äh in die Zelle sich hinein äh,
aktiviert und das ist so ein Weg, den äh das Virus bisher nicht äh gewählt hat.
Weil ähm für diesen anderen Weg sind diese Interphirone ins Spiel kommen, die das irgendwie verhindern und offenbar kein OmiCroren, die sind da für.
Austricksen hat da äh eine entsprechende Anpassung, sodass dieser Weg ihm wieder,
offen steht oder offener steht als das eben bei den anderen Varianten der Fall war,
Und ja, das bedeutet ähm dass überall da, wo bisher diese Interphirone gegengearbeitet haben, um die Krone jetzt leichter reinkommt und das ist halt genau dieser Bereich,
Aachen Obera äh Teil. Also das das passt alles ganz gut ähm zusammen und äh das ist so ein bisschen.
Der Grund, warum das jetzt alles so fit ist, warum das irgendwie alles so schnell geht.
Ja
Ja, ich hatte eigentlich so im in Erinnerung im Kopf, dass auch die anderen Varianten äh so mit der äh.
Die Interferon-Antwort äh blockieren beziehungsweise mit dem ja das System unterdrücken.
Ja, aber kann gut sein, dass das bei OmiCronn äh jetzt nochmal in einem größeren Ausmaß erfolgt oder effizienter äh passiert.
Ähm ja.
Vielleicht noch ein Wort zu den Varianten, die jetzt wieder diskutiert werden, also die Untervarianten von äh Omicron.
Da gibt's jetzt irgendwie diese schöne Bezeichnung BA Punkt 1 und B A Punkt 2. Das sind jetzt sozusagen so 2 separate Nachfolgevarianten von dem Ur-Omicron.
Da sieht's wohl gerade so aus, als ob dieses BA2 BA eins gerade verdrängt,
Da müssen wir uns aber keine großen Sorgen machen. Das ist im Wesentlichen immer noch scheint bloß noch mal zwanzig Prozent schneller zu sein.
Als diese äh Einservariante, also,
Irgendwie schafft's OmiCroin sogar noch weiter den Turbo einzulegen, aber wir befinden uns halt immer noch in dem selben symptomatischen Feld. Was ja so eine,
so ein bisschen so die Angst ist, die bei uns allen so ein bisschen im Nacken ist so, okay, was passiert, wenn man jetzt eine Virusvariante haben, die sich noch schneller.
Ausbreiten kann.
Aber dann trotzdem auf einmal wieder tödlicher ist. Ne, das ist ja bisher eigentlich das, was wir man stelle sich jetzt mal nur vor, so wie sich OmiCron jetzt ausbreitet mit der Power von Delta.
Ne, das das wäre eine totale Katastrophe. Da hätten wir auch wenig gegen tun können. Da, ne, also klar, dann in zwei, drei Monaten hätten wir dann da wieder einen Impfstoff gehabt und so weiter, aber das das wäre jetzt wirklich eine Bulldozer äh Situation gewesen. Nur.
Eben gerade schon versucht habe so darzustellen. Das eine hängt mit dem anderen zusammen. Also dieses ist nicht so gefährlich,
hat eben genau mit diesem Fitnessfaktor, ich kann mich besser verbreiten, auch zu tun, weil's halt einfach die Lunge auslässt oder zumindest nicht mehr in dem Maße äh attackiert und daraus kann man glaube ich schon.
Schließen fürs Erste dass ähm.
Zumindest solange jetzt Omikron äh regiert. Da müsste halt schon irgendwas kommen, was nochmal ganz anders funktioniert. Also so diese Fitness, die sich da jetzt grade bei Omicron weiterentwickelt, die optimiert einfach weiter auf das schnelle rein raus.
Geht gar nicht mehr so sehr auf den Leib. Und das ist eigentlich eine ganz gute.
Äh eine gute Nachricht. Es gab dann ja zwischendurch noch so diese Meldung. Es es es gäbe irgendso eine Melange aus aus Delta und und und Omicron. Ist los, war irgend so ein.
Griechisches Labor oder so was das gemeldet hat so und dann ging das ja schnell rum und jetzt kommt Delta Con.
Genau mit dieser Vermutung so, oh jetzt haben wir das Schlimmste von Delta mit dem Schlimmsten von OmiCronn in einem. Das,
Gibt's nicht. Also das war ziemlich sicher war das eine Verunreinigung im Labor beim Überprüfen von Proben,
sagen eigentlich alle, die sich das angeschaut haben, ist ja auch mittlerweile später raus aus den Nachrichten. Es war halt so ein so ein kurzer Angstschauer. Aber das, das ist einfach nicht der Fall und.
Auch wahrscheinlich sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass das passieren würde, weil,
Wahrscheinlich erstmal schon gesehen aber verdrängt einfach Delta, das hatten wir ja hier schon äh diskutiert und andererseits sind einfach auch diese beiden Varianten dann doch sehr unterschiedlich, weil die.
Ist ja nicht so, dass Omi Omikron ist ja keine Weiterentwicklung von Delta. Ja, also während Delta halt schon eine Weiterentwicklung von Alpha war oder ist alles mehr oder weniger so aus diesem selben Stammbaumbereich äh kam.
Ist halt OmiCron ja im Prinzip so ein.
So eine Zeitreise gewesen. Ja also auf einmal haben wir's mit einer Variante zu tun die ihren Ursprung.
Hat in irgendetwas, wo sich dieses Virus an sich im Sommer 2020 befunden hat.
Dann irgendwie ein Jahr lang unentdeckt sich irgendwie weiterentwickelt hat, wo auch immer, ja. Wir hatten ja die Theorie-Mäuse unklar,
eigentlich auch egal, hat sich auf jeden Fall weiterentwickelt. Ist dann irgendwie wieder einen Menschen zu Tage getreten und hat dann eben seinen Fitnessvorteil voll ausgespielt. Und von daher nehme ich an,
Werden wir jetzt eben dieses Spiel, was wir jetzt äh spielen, das neue Spiel, das spielen wir jetzt mit äh OmiCronn und seinen Nachfahren.
Stellt sich jetzt die Frage ist jetzt schon alles vorbei?
War's das, ja. Der äh Thomas Poeo.
Französischer Analytiker, keinen Virologe, sondern jemand, der ähm.
Diesen bemerkenswerten Text äh seinerzeit geschrieben hat, also diese ganze Theorie, die er auch von Drosten,
als ähm Gedankenmodell schnell aufgegriffen wurde, so dieses oh jetzt haben wir eine böse pandemische Situation. Jetzt müssen wir irgendwie draufhauen, Lockdowns machen.
Dann äh das sozusagen runterkriegen und dann müssen wir den Tanz machen, ne, so einen Maßnahmentanz machen, um irgendwie das irgendwie in den Griff zu bekommen und im Wesentlichen ist es ja so gelaufen. Also da kommt sozusagen dieser Begriff her von Thomas äh,
selber ist er halt irgendwie mehr so ein Tech geil, aber eine interessante analytische äh Denke und der hat.
Äh äh weiß nicht, ob das auch von ihm ist oder äh es aber äh ist im Prinzip dieselbe dieselbe äh Kerbe äh.
Ja, nee, ich glaube nicht, dass das auf ihn zurückzuführen ist, wenn wir jetzt auf jeden Fall neu. Ähm wie auch immer, er hat jetzt äh einen Artikel geschrieben ähm Corona.
Genannt äh Coronavirus game over und ähm ja im Kern sind seine Thesen,
Okay, wir sind jetzt am Ende der Pandemie angekommen. So und warum? Erstmal wir haben Impfstoffe, Impfstoffe reduzieren.
Todeszahlen, 90 Prozent. Wir haben OmiCrorn. Omikron tötet 90 Prozent weniger und wir haben Parkslowvide.
Sorgt dafür, dass weitere 90 Prozent von denen, die äh schon jetzt anfangen, hier einen bösen Verlauf zu haben.
Dass auch die nicht sterben müssen.
Und 3 mal 90 Prozent heißt, wir haben halt irgendwie eine Gefahrenreduktion am Horizont von 99,9 Prozent und.
Er sagt halt okay it's time to think about the future. Jetzt müssen wir sozusagen.
Im anblick des Pandemie-Endes, darüber nachdenken, wie wir jetzt damit umgehen, wie wir auch sagen wir mal mit dem wie wir jetzt auch dieses Ende zelebrieren oder also nicht feiern, sondern wie wir das sozusagen,
handhaben, welche Maßnahmen sind denn jetzt.
Die richtigen Maßnahmen und das finde ich wirklich eine sehr interessantes Gedankenmodell, denn.
Und das betrifft ja auch unsere Debatte, ne. Wir haben ja hier vor einem Jahr viel geklagter drüber
dass wir diese äh Lockdown-Karte nicht stärker gezogen haben. Das galt für die zweite Welle im Oktober, die ja dann relativ stark war. Das galt dann aber auch, um noch mal die dritte Welle,
nieder zu treten so.
Auch nicht gelungen ist, wodurch sich dieses ganze Elend im letzten Winter ja wirklich bis in den Mai gezogen hat. Was.
Vermeidbar gewesen wäre oder zumindest in einem bestimmten Maße hätte.
Werden können. Also mit einem harten Lockdown im November oder auch noch mal mit einem länger durchgehaltenen Lockdown im das war das Februar März.
Ähm hätten wir uns einige Monate ersparen können. Will jetzt nicht genau sagen, solange wär's dann kürzer gewesen, aber es ist schon klar, dass dass der Winter nicht ganz so stressig.
Geworden wäre, nicht so viel wirtschaftlichen Schaden,
anrichten müssen, nicht so viel sozialen Schaden hätte anrichten müssen und natürlich am Ende auch nicht so viel finanziellen Schaden hätte anrichten müssen
Egal. Das ist jetzt Vergangenheit, können wir nicht mehr ändern. Nur worauf ich hinaus will ist, wir haben relativ zwei Mal relativ klare Position bezogen und gesagt, okay, ja hier Lockdown irgendwie wo bleibt der, warum warum können wir denn das nicht richtig machen, weil wenn wir's
weil wir's nicht richtig machen, ziehen wir alles nur in die Länge. Und jetzt haben wir irgendwie eine neue Situation und die neue Situation ist irgendwie anders.
Wie eben schon aufgezählt. So, wir haben eine andere Impfsituation. Wir haben eine andere Medikamentensituation und wir haben halt jetzt auch noch glücklicherweise auch noch eine noch eine komplett neue Virussituation und die ganzen Zahlen, die wir jetzt gesehen haben,
erzählen eigentlich die Story folgendermaßen. Wir werden jetzt in den nächsten zwei Wochen, drei Wochen, vier Wochen.
Extrem hohe.
Inzidenzen sehen, wie wir es jetzt in Berlin sehen. In Berlin sind wir bei 2000 gemessen. Wir sind wahrscheinlich bei fünftausend Real.
Fünf Prozent, also in dieser einen Altersgruppe der der Jugendlichen hatten wir diese Zahl gesehen, so kann aber gut sein, dass wir das,
in einer Woche auch in in ganz Deutschland sehen. Weil das wir uns zumindest dem hochtig annähern. Ja und das also wirklich.
Nicht mehr in in Promille messen, sondern dass wir in Prozent messen, wie viele Leute sich gerade irgendwie infiziert haben. Und.
Das wird zwangsläufig dann irgendwann dazu führen, dass einfach die meisten sich einfach angesteckt haben. So ist die allermeisten. Und dann gehen die Zahlen wieder runter.
Ja, okay.
Das ist so jetzt mal die die Arbeitsthese sozusagen, ne. Das zeichnet sich jetzt ab und wie gehen wir damit um?
Ja äh also grundsätzlich hat er ja Recht oder hast hast du Recht mit dem ähm es ist vorbei, aber es ist halt,
heute vorbei. So aus verschiedenen Gründen. Erstens diese 90 Prozent von Pax Louis sind noch nicht da.
Hoffentlich bald, aber dann sind schon mal neunzig Prozent. So und dann ähm.
Ist der gesamte Schutz oder oder Verlaufsschutz äh sage ich mal, ist halt dann auch eben nur noch Faktor drei, wenn man sich einmal angesteckt,
So das heißt ähm ein Drittel der Leute haben dann trotzdem einen schweren Verlauf äh die sich die sich anstecken. So ähm.
Ja äh das kann sich natürlich ändern. Das wird sich ändern, äh wenn eine Omikon,
Impfung äh da ist und hm ja ich denke äh es gibt gute Chancen.
Wahrscheinlich fifty fifty oder so, um äh bis März, April ähm sich dann auch einfach nicht zu,
infizieren, ja? Gilt vielleicht nicht für jeden so ähm je nach je nach Job, äh den den man hat, aber ähm,
Ja äh das Virus wird sich nicht durch die gesamte Bevölkerung äh brennen, sage ich mal. Und ich würde schon
eher lieber zu denen gehören, äh so wo es sich auch nicht durchgebrannt hat, mir dann irgendwann im März oder April oder so nochmal eine äh einen Varianten
äh Booster geben lassen und dann ist es für mich wäre es für mich idealerweise zu Ende.
Ja? So, weil dann weiß ich, dann habe ich halt irgendwie äh durch meine dreifach Booster jetzt äh
wie du auch durch durch die Yolo äh Impfung oder wie auch immer äh man sie nennen mag, äh dann noch eine eine vierte Variante und dann,
Ist für mich das wäre für mich das Thema auch erstmal durch. So sehe ich das. Aber ähm ja ich,
muss jetzt nicht rausgehen und mir irgendwie äh eine eine Omi-Kronimpfung äh durch ein,
Leben des Virus jetzt holen, ja. Das ist ein das ist ein ziemlich riskanter Impfstoff im Moment. Ähm auf der anderen Seite
wenn ich irgendwie wirklich was Wichtiges zu tun hätte oder aus wichtigen Grund würde ich jetzt auch mein Leben nicht mehr komplett auf den Kopf stellen äh um den Kontakt zu vermeiden. So
aber ich würde ihn definitiv nicht suchen und äh wenn es denn ohne,
allzu viele Mühen ähm oder Entbehrungen äh oder so möglich ist. So ähm.
Ja ähm mich mich einfach schützen.
Absolut nachvollziehbare persönliche Perspektive, ja? Die Perspektive, die Thomas Poyer jetzt hier aber hier aufmacht, ist.
In Anbetracht einer gestiegenen, vielleicht sogar schon hohen Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass wir sozusagen auf so ein Pandemieende.
Hinauslaufen, ja? Und ich meine, du du kannst dich jetzt schützen oder deine kann sich jetzt so schützen, wie viel sie will und für richtig hält, dass es so persönliches äh,
Gibt ja auch Leute, die da komplett drauf verzichten. So ja, impfen muss ich nicht machen und so weiter, mir doch egal. Ich trage keine Maske.
Okay, your risk, äh wir haben alle versucht, alles äh für euch zu tun so. Und ich sage jetzt mal, Gretel ist auch noch nicht über den nächsten Winter, weil es erstmal nur so wie wie klingt das jetzt irgendwie aus. Und,
Das wird jetzt wahrscheinlich einfach über Infektionen mit Omicron-Lauf, sehen wir ja gerade. Findet einfach statt, ja? Also
Klar, es gibt dann so zehn Prozent, die entweder nicht zu erreichen sind oder sich nicht erreichen lassen wollen oder beides, dass es dann eben äh
quasi dann so die persönliche Entscheidung, wann wann geht man so aus seinem inneren Lockdown raus? Ja, indem ich zum Beispiel jetzt auch irgendwie noch
bin. So ich äh heißt nicht, dass ich jetzt mir gar nichts gönne, aber wenn dann bin ich irgendwie auch immer noch,
vorsichtig und manches lasse ich halt einfach von vornherein
komplett sein. Andere können das nicht, der Job gibt es nicht oder hat auch keinen Bock mehr drauf. Und generell ist es natürlich auch so, dass dieser fortwährende Alarmzustand und das sehen wir ja auch.
Äh an der Quote, wie die Leute so frei drehen.
So oder so nicht mehr lange zu halten wäre. Das heißt, jetzt ist so der Zeitpunkt gekommen, wo man eben die nächsten Schritte diskutieren muss. Ne, was was ist das jetzt so? Und ich denke, es läuft schon darauf hinaus, dass man jetzt,
zumindest keine weiteren Verschärfungen mehr.
Bringen kann. Erst mal unabhängig von solchen Debatten wie der Impfpflicht so, aber was jetzt so die eigentlichen Maßnahmen betrifft. Ich denke, wir haben so so ein bisschen das Maximum an Maßnahmen erreicht.
Und ab jetzt gilt es nur den richtigen Pace zu finden. Diese schrittweise zurückzunehmen. Man sieht ja schon die ersten.
Was weiß ich jetzt mit Veranstaltungen im Freien, ne, Fußballspiele, Bundesliga ist ja auch wieder so auf gar keine Zuschauer runtergedreht wurden, wo man sie halt auch fragst, okay, muss es jetzt noch sein? Weil ist es jetzt nicht so
man's den Leuten auch quasi die Risikoeinschätzung selber überlassen kann,
ob sie jetzt wirklich ins Stadion gehen wollen, ob sie sich sozusagen in so eine Situation bringen wollen.
Weil es jetzt einfach nicht mehr so sehr die kollektive äh Sache ist. Ich weiß nicht, gibt's jetzt die andere Seite? Gerade aus der Perspektive der Kinder-Immung geschwächten et cetera.
Ja? Und das sagte er auch in seinem Artikel, für die wird es natürlich nach wie vor ein Problem sein und die müssen dann unter Umständen eben auch aus ihr in ihrem inneren Lockdown bleiben.
So ist denn für sie überhaupt möglich ist, Stichwort Schulen.
Ähm nur wir müssen halt jetzt neu austarieren wie welche Belastung Gesamtbelastung der Gesellschaft wollen wir denn jetzt noch weiterhin haben, weil es ja auch,
viele, viele, viele, viele andere Folgen hat. Wirtschaft, Veranstaltungsbranche, Geld, äh was die ganzen Maßnahmen kosten et cetera.
Mhm ich meine gut, was.
Halt, wenn es es ist, das alte Dilemma jetzt mit neu verschobenen,
Reglern äh so ein bisschen, aber ähm die grundsätzliche Frage ist, die mir stellt, so,
wie viele.
Leute will man jetzt, um welchen Preis äh ohne Omi-Kron-Infektionen ähm durch die aktuelle Welle bringen.
Ja, weil ich meine es ist äh also zum einen ähm können wir auch davon ausgehen, dass wenn's jetzt demnächst hoffentlich auch wieder bald wärmer wird äh irgendwann ähm wahrscheinlich auch äh sich das bemerkbar,
wird und äh dann äh ja Impfstoff äh ist halt dann die andere Sache und da wissen wir halt ähm ja das,
sondern so einen Omi-Kron-Impfstoff, äh selbst wenn,
der dann nicht irgendwie ewig wirkt oder nicht vor Ansteckung äh äh schützt. So würde dann aber auch langfristig erst mal für so eine Grund
Immunität sorgen dann gegenüber auch allen Varianten auf eine mildere Art, als wenn wir jetzt alle Leute durchinfizieren. So. Wir hatten jetzt, wir sind schon, wir können jetzt.
Aber eine also Zero-Covid funktioniert auch nicht. Er würde sogar jetzt gesagt irgendwie ja China, dadurch dass die jetzt jetzt fällt ihnen Zero covid auf die Füße, weil jetzt müssen sie irgendwie alle durchinfizieren und äh aber,
Nee, eigentlich was du haben möchtest, ist äh dass du's,
Irgendwann laufen lassen kannst, weil das Virus dann aber auf eine geimpfte Bevölkerung äh trifft und dann nur die Ungeimpften äh in einem kleinen Prozess hat's ungeimpfter äh trifft und äh dann
ganz ganz junger Menschen, die äh also Kinder, die sich das dann erstmalig
holen in den ersten Lebensjahren, wie das mit allen anderen Krankheiten auch ist, die dann aber vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen Grundimmunität von der Mutter äh vermittelt kriegen, so in den Zustand äh wollen wir ja
wir ja gelangen und aus meiner Sicht äh ja kommen ja äh wäre eben,
vorzuziehen, wenn wir in den Zustand kommen, dass wir möglichst viele äh Leute,
durch Impfung eine Immunität geben ähm statt dass wir äh die Omega-Variante komplett.
Laufen Variante statt dass wir die Omikron Variante komplett durchlaufen lassen. So aber so auf der anderen Seite ja ähm.
Kontrolle, die wir haben, äh ist eben auch begrenzt. So, was aber nicht heißt, dass nur, weil man jetzt nicht alles völlig unter Kontrolle hat, dass man jetzt komplett äh
aufhören sollte ähm irgendeine ähm Art von Kontrolle auszuüben und vielleicht,
weiß ich nicht, zehn, zwanzig, dreißig Prozent mehr der Leute ähm über die Impfung äh in den indemischen Zustand zu bringen am Ende als äh über eine Erstinfektion mit.
Um Mikron.
Ja gut, aber zu welchem Preis? Ne, also das das ist halt jetzt wirklich äh die Frage,
So und und der Preis, den wir jetzt alle bezahlt haben, ist relativ hoch. Also sogar ich habe jetzt langsam die Schnauze voll.
Womit ich jetzt nicht sagen wollte, ja, so Pandemie zwanzig20, ich war dabei und ich trage so ein Tourshirt, das nicht nur.
Ich konnte und da hat ja auch dieser Podcast enorm geholfen, ja. Dadurch, dass ich mich drauf konzentriert habe, dann das auch akzeptiert habe, dass es halt einfach so ist. So und das ist dann auch so so ein bisschen zu so meinem.
Ähm Debatten, Inhalt beim täglichen, wöchentlichen, monatlichen Debatteninhalt gemacht habe.
Mit der Situation mehr anfreunden und das ist natürlich auch eine extrem privilegierte,
äh Positionen, aus der ich das heraus habe machen können, aber sogar bei mir ist jetzt irgendwie langsam also der Spaß ist jetzt einfach vorbei, so ich habe jetzt einfach überhaupt gar keinen Bock mehr auf ähm,
Beschränkungen, die jetzt sozusagen geprägt sind aus der Ist-Situation von vor einem Jahr, weil die Ist-Situation ist halt jetzt anders, ne. Ich bin,
nach wie vor für eine Impfpflicht
Weil ich denke, gerade in Abwesenheit von solchen Beschränkungen braucht's eben einen Druck, um diesen anderen Zustand herzustellen, von dem du jetzt grade gesagt hast, wäre gut, ne und der wird dann wahrscheinlich im Winter dann eben nochmal eine größere Rolle spielen.
Also so eine Kombination aus Lockerungen plus Impfpflicht,
denke ich mal, das das könnte ein Pfad sein, ne. Und andere Länder machen das ja schon, ne. Also in in Schottland werden jetzt am Montag irgendwie im Wesentlichen diese ganzen Beschränkungen im Gastbereich.
Restaurants, Hotels et cetera aufgehoben. Klar, ne, die sind auch schon weiter äh voran. Die haben früher Omikron bekommen und sind halt mehr geimpft.
Also im Grunde genommen kann man zumindest, also ist mein Gefühl in Berlin, kann man,
sagen alles machen, aber äh wir sind nicht im Lockdown. So man kann ausgehen irgendwie, man kann
Kneipe sitzen und ein Bier trinken, man kann essen äh gehen, man kann im Hotel übernachten, so ähm also,
all diese, ich sage mal, wirklich heftigen äh Dinge äh so äh ja.
Sagen harten Lockdown in in dem Sinne haben wir ja nicht, was was bleibt also sind sind im Wesentlichen noch Maskenmandate.
Und.
Veranstaltungsbeschränkungen, also.
Genau und ja und leider die Veranstaltungsbeschränkungen, genau.
Ja, an diesen die sind schon massiv.
Und ja ja und äh da sehe ich es aber auch so wie du, äh dass man in den Bereichen
es äh tatsächlich dann auch wahrscheinlich den Leuten überlassen könnte, wobei man ja,
Auf der anderen Seite, wenn die wenn die Zahlen explodieren gerade, ist äh vielleicht auch nicht.
Ich rede ja nicht von heute, sondern ich rede ja von, ne, wir reden jetzt von einem Zeitpunkt, der absehbar ist. Das ist das Ding.
Absehbar und ich würde jetzt mal unsere Zahlensituation in Deutschland. Bin nach wie vor der Meinung, Ende Februar.
Sind wir über einen Berg. Vielleicht sind wir noch nicht über den Berg, aber wir sind auf jeden Fall über einen Berg hin hinweg geschritten so und mit der Perspektive, das ist grade dann im,
weiteren Verlauf zum Sommer hin sich nicht mehr verschlimmert. So und ähm jetzt muss eben die Politik sich darauf einstellen äh hier die richtige Balance zu finden und meiner Meinung nach,
muss es eben,
konsequenter, schrittweiser Abbau der Beschränkungen sein, sodass es auch eine Perspektive gibt. Das hatten wir auch letztes Jahr schon diskutiert. Ja, dass wenn man Lockerungen macht, dass man,
klare Bedingungen nennt, sie schon mal in Aussicht stellt, sagt, wenn diese Bedingungen erfüllt ist, dann ist das nicht mehr, dann ist das nicht mehr und das kommt alles
ja? Wir brauchen jetzt keinen Freedom-Day, wo irgendwie
war alles ganz schlimm und morgen ist äh überhaupt nichts mehr. Sondern das es irgendwie klar ist, dass man wieder planen kann, dass man wieder irgendwie eine Perspektive haben kann, dass man sagen kann, okay, alles klar, im März ist das wieder möglich et cetera et cetera et cetera
und dann ähm denke ich mal wird es auch eine entsprechende Akzeptanz finden, ne. Plus eben dann eben die die Impfpflicht, von der ich nicht weiß, ob Deutschland wirklich,
es schaffen wird, sie zu beschließen, kann man vielleicht auch gleich noch mal einen Tipp zu abgeben.
Meiner Meinung nach sollte sie halt kommen, andere Leute sind anderer Meinung, egal. So, käme sie
man sozusagen dieses Parallele äh Ding, so diese Ansage an die Gesellschaft, es wird von euch eigentlich erwartet, dass ihr jetzt euren Teil leistet,
damit wir zum nächsten Herbst eine Situation haben, in der uns.
Welche Variante dann auch immer irgendwie aktuell ist, ja nicht wieder äh so sehr auf die Füße tritt, dass wir in irgendeiner Form wieder in diesem ganzen Schlammer so lang.
Das ist vermeidbar.
Ich meine, das ist
natürlich dann noch noch das das nächste Ding äh so, dass man äh vielleicht auch überlegen äh sollte, so wie man dann die nächste Pandemie vielleicht ein bisschen besser gefahren,
kriegt, aber wie wir jetzt auch sehen, es kommt jede Pandemie so ein bisschen mit ihren eigenen Gesetzen, äh wo es äh je nach Beschaffenheit des Virus und seinen Eigenschaften.
Ähm ganz unterschiedliche äh Dinge Sinn machen, aber,
so das das Thema Masken beispielsweise wissen wir also Masken schützen halt äh,
vor fast allem. Äh ja, das ist also wissen wir schon. Das ist halt ähm.
Ja äh äh will aber auch auch auch auf die Zukunft äh äh gesehen und.
Ähm ja, ansonsten sehe ich, dass das ähnlich, dass dass dieser, dass dieser Zeitpunkt kommen wird und dass im Grunde genommen.
Äh ja ähm wenn entweder die Zahlen in den
Keller gehen oder dann ein neuer Impfstoff verfügbar wird oder Pax Nous verfügbar wird oder alles alles zusammen.
Dann passiert wenn wir tatsächlich irgendwann in den nächsten Wochen oder spätestens zwei Monaten glaube ich tatsächlich den Punkt
überschritten haben, wo wir dann sagen können, ja es ist jetzt erstmal vorbei. So bis zur nächsten Pandemie.
Hm. Ja. Das unser Wort.
Sonntag an der Stelle. Ähm ich wollte jetzt nochmal.
Kurz noch mal so in den Bereich äh Impfstoffe reingehen, weil das ist ja nur grad schon angesprochen, haben schon noch ein Thema, ne. Auf der einen Seite,
äh soll der angepasste Impfstoff an Omigran angepasste Impfstoff von Biontech und Pfizer kommen. Aktuelle Schätzungen der Unternehmen ist glaube ich März.
Wird sich dann halt zeigen, aber ich denke mal, die,
können das ganz gut äh einschätzen, wann's dann eben wirklich distribuiert ist und in Umlauf kommt und wie dann eben die Regelungen sein werden äh wie man da rankommt und wer das äh
sich boostern darf et cetera, das ist dann nochmal eine andere Geschichte.
Aber das das kommt, ne. Was auch kommt, ist der Nova Wax Impfstoff, der soll angeblich am.
Ende Februar 21.2 ist hier glaube ich die Erwartungshaltung gerade
auch noch mit dazu kommen. Da habe ich jetzt zwar keine großen äh Hoffnungen drauf, aber wenn das irgendwie ein Impfstoff ist, der jetzt irgendwie Leuten mehr zusagt und dann dann sind sie dabei.
Dann äh soll's mir recht sein.
Wenn ich das in Erinnerung habe, ist das jetzt nicht der äh ja ist das jetzt nicht der allerbeste äh aller Impfstoffe, was jetzt so den den Schutzfaktor
angeht und äh es auch nicht auf Omi-Con jetzt angepasst, ne. Das ist halt ja.
Ja muss man schauen. Also wie gesagt, ich habe äh ich halte da meine Atem nicht an ähm aber meinetwegen wenn wenn Leute zu was anderem nicht zu äh hohlen sind, dann meinetwegen.
Ja ähm Impfung. Was wolltest du jetzt noch.
Na ja, ich wollte jetzt nochmal auf was anderes nämlich hinaus von Bier und Tech und zwar hat Biontech eine Pressemitteilung rausgehauen. Da habe ich nicht schlecht gestaunt. Das ist vom elften Januar zweiundzwanzig. Also jetzt schon zwei Wochen her. Ist gar nicht so viel drüber diskutiert worden.
Und zwar ähm haben sie bekannt gegeben, dass sie ein Frühwarnsystem zur Erkennung,
potentieller Hochrisikovarianten von SARS-CoV-zwei entwickelt haben und zwar in Zusammenarbeit mit einem britischen Unternehmen mit dem schönen Namen Instadieb.
Und äh Eingeweihte ahnen schon, was hier dahinter steht, ja, es ist halt
jetzt hätte ich fast künstliche Intelligenz gesagt. Nein, nein, also Machine Learning äh ist also fällt natürlich in die Kategorie, künstliche Intelligenz, aber der Begriff hat hier eigentlich wenig zu suchen. Learning ist halt,
ist uns.
Wenn Leute heute von künstlicher Intelligenz reden, dann meinen sie eigentlich Machine Learning. Ne, das ist sozusagen die derzeit dominante Methode, mit der man einfach aus diffusen Datenmaterial interessante Schlüsse ziehen kann.
Was haben Sie jetzt gemacht? Sie haben also ein äh System aufgebaut, das Sie permanent mit allen Sequenzierungsinformationen, die weltweit gewonnen werden,
füttern. Da kommt dann auch diese schöne Zahl äh raus, dass sie pro Woche musste ja ich mir jetzt mal geben,
pro Woche haben wir es mit derzeit ungefähr 10.000 neuen Varianten zu tun. Wohlgemerkt nicht
Varianten äh der Besorgnis, also keine Variance of Concern
äh auch nicht äh Warance under Investigations. Das sind dann immer nur die, wo man sagt so okay, hier ist eine Schwelle überschritten worden. Hier äh hat sich das Verhalten geändert und dann hält sich unter Umständen das eben.
Verhalten in einer besorgniserregenden Dimension.
Verändern. Nein, hier geht's einfach generell um die fortlaufende Mutation des Virus. Aber die werden ja sequenziert und diese Sequenzierungsergebnisse fließen in diese Datenbank ein.
Und dieses System schaut sich diese Varianten an und bewertet sie.
Versucht eine Aussage darüber zu fällen, wie gefährlich oder ja wie wie sich diese Variante,
voraussichtlich auf,
das Immunsystem auswirkt oder äh mit welcher Fitness dieses Virus, also diese Virusvariante daherkommt, ne. Also wie gefährlich es für den Körper auf der einen Seite und wie fit ist es, also wie gut kann es sich eben verbreiten,
Und da haben sie ein paar bemerkenswerte,
Behauptungen gemacht. Sie meinten im Versuchszeitraum, der jetzt in den letzten Monaten äh gelegen haben dürfte, äh identifizierte dieses System,
durchschnittlich mehr als 90 Prozent der von der WHO deklarierten Varianten,
und zwar zwei Monate vor deren offizieller Ausweisung.
Also zwei Monate bevor die WHO sagt, hier ist irgendwie eine Variante, die hat irgendwie jetzt so einen besonderen Stellenwert, also was ich gerade gesagt habe, Investigation oder eben äh Konzern. 90 Prozent davon hätten sie mit ihrem System
zwei Monate vorher erkannt haben, erkannt.
Und äh sie können dann halt sie machen sowohl eine Bewertung mit was sie denken, wie sich die Variante auf das Immunsystem auswirkt und dann eben welche Fitness es äh bringt.
Ja und das äh wollen sie demnächst irgendwie ähm als Studie veröffentlichen, die halt noch nicht äh veröffentlicht. Das Ganze ist halt eine Pressemitteilung.
Und OmiCronn ähm nee,
Alpha Beta Gamma, Theta, ETA und Omikron.
Wurden von diesem System in derselben Woche erkannt, in der die Sequenz das erste Mal hochgeladen wurde.
Die OmiCronn Variante konkret wurde noch am selben Tag, an dem die Sequenz verfügbar wurde, als Hochrisikovariante eingestuft.
Mhm.
Ja, ich meine, man müsste natürlich da jetzt dann die äh gesamte äh Studie natürlich sehen. Ich meine, grundsätzlich,
ist da jetzt nix äh gegen zu sagen, allerdings tummelt sich natürlich in diesem Feld jetzt äh so deep learning tummelt sich halt vieles, beziehungsweise ähm.
Ein Merkmal äh dieser tiefen neuronalen Netze ist es halt, dass sie eben auch,
Fehler machen können. So ähm und äh,
mit den 90 Prozent der Varianten, äh die da identifiziert worden sind, müsste man jetzt halt auch noch wissen, ähm ja,
wie viele Varianten sind denn möglicherweise fälschlich äh auch äh ähm identifiziert worden als äh potentiell riskant so und 90 Prozent ist jetzt.
Ja, also so rum.
Ähm so machine Learning ähm oder auch deep learning wird halt in der Astronomie zum Beispiel auch sehr erfolgreich eingesetzt, um so äh ja die die,
die ganzen Telesdaten von den Teleskopen nach irgendwelchen neuen Phänomenen, Supernovy oder ähm Asteroiden.
Kometen Planeten, wie auch immer, abzusuchen und ähm.
Da werden dann eben bestimmte Ausschnitte dann markiert und die kriegt dann halt ein Review zu sehen und guckt sich die dann von Hand an, so.
Klingt erst mal alles ganz gut, aber die Astronomen zum Beispiel
kritisieren das Ganze auch, weil man eben auf diese Weise auch nur Phänomene finden kann, äh nach denen man sucht, während sagen früher, wenn man sich die Dinger
früher angeguckt hat, dann ist man plötzlich auf überraschende Dinge gestoßen äh nach denen man gar nicht gesucht hat, weil sie eben gar nicht,
existierten und so ist natürlich auch ein bisschen das das Problem äh mit,
mit den Varianten so, dass natürlich das System nur
Varianten erkennen kann, die,
Ähm ja an an bestimmten Stellen, von denen bekannt ist. Äh so ähm.
Dass diese diese kritisch äh sind. So äh die zu finden. Er will sagen man kann auch äh eben äh das System kann eben auch eine ganze Menge übersehen.
Aber äh du setzt natürlich jetzt voraus, dass es sich hier um ausschließlich um eine maschinelearningbasierte äh,
Vorgehensweise handeln würde. Dem ist nicht so, sondern das ist nur einer von zwei Ansätzen. Ja, also mit diesem Learning ähm,
Mit deren Vorhersagemodellen ähm damit.
Bestimmen sie sozusagen so die die die Sample. Also damit finden sie sozusagen die die ihnen verdächtig vorkommen.
Und die eigentliche Bewertung,
basiert aber nicht ausschließlich auf dem bisher Gelernten, sondern das handelt, da handelt es sich jetzt sozusagen also wir haben ja jetzt auch eine Kooperation. Wir haben Biotechn, wir haben Inside Deep Inside Deep ist sozusagen für dieses Vorsortieren und dieses Raussuchen ähm.
Zuständig. Ich interpretiere jetzt mal so ein bisschen, was sie in ihrer Pressemitteilung gesagt haben. Die eigentliche Bewertung,
eine Variante jetzt gefährlich ist oder nicht, also ob da die Fitness erhöht ist oder so weiter. Das ist tatsächlich eine strukturelle Modellierung der Interaktion.
Von dieser äh RBD, von dieser Rezeptor bindenden äh Domäne des Bike Proteins mit dem,
äh und der entsprechenden Bewölkung äh der Bewertung dieser Auswirkungen ähm,
auf das Immunsystem. Also ihr kommt zwei Sachen zusammen, also wirklich ein ein biologisches Modell.
Ja, wo sie sagen, aha, okay, auf Basis dieser Proteinfaltung und so weiter, keine Ahnung, was sie da äh heranziehen, äh erwarten wir eben folgende äh Auswirkungen. So und.
Ist eine Pressemitteilung, ja? Also muss man jetzt abwarten oder so. Fand ich ich sage ja auch nur, ich finde das bemerkenswert. Ich fand das sozusagen bemerkenswert, dass sie so was überhaupt bauen.
Ja und ich fand's auch bemerkenswert, wie sie's bauen, dass sie nämlich auf der einen Seite mit einem Machine Learning rangehen und sagen okay, in diesem riesigen Sandkasten zehntausend Varianten pro Woche suchen wir uns irgendwie erst mal was raus, was irgendwie
auffällig ist und da gibt's dann eben entsprechende die hier zum Tragen kommen aber das was wir ausgewählt haben das fahren wir jetzt eben wirklich durch so ein Biosimulator sage ich mal ganz äh platt,
auf Basis unserer virologischen äh Erkenntnislage, die sie als Biontech äh haben und machen dann eben entsprechende ähm Aussagen über voraus äh.
Aussagen über die wahrscheinliche Immunantwort und auf die wahrscheinliche Fitness. So und wenn Sie sagen, okay, wir haben irgendwie alle griechischen Buchstaben im Wesentlichen äh innerhalb einer Woche erkannt.
Omikron irgendwie am Same Day sage ich erstmal okay, alles klar, seht ihr's nicht so aus, als ob's nicht funktionieren würde. Wenn das stimmt, ne.
Weniger. Finde ich auf jeden Fall gut, wo sie da auch äh rangehen überhaupt.
Also ich würd's würd's jetzt nicht so sagen, meine Sicht, ich würd's jetzt nicht von vornherein als Unsinn äh abtun.
So, nur nur weil äh sie eben dort auch die
Learning äh machen. Es kommt immer eben ganz drauf drauf an äh so was das was Ziel und und Zweck der ganzen Geschichte ist äh
und äh ja und,
wenn sie's dann durchsimulieren oder ich sage mal zum zum Screen großer Datenmengen äh nach bestimmten Mustern, die man nicht genau kennt, wo man aber,
anderes Datenmaterial hat, das
ähnliche Muster aufweist, so dafür äh funktioniert das halt hervorragend so. Also es ist alles eine Frage auch des Trainingsmaterials, was man hat und wie wie man die Netze trainiert und wie man's dann einsetzt und
äh wie man sagen die Ergebnisse interpretiert, die dann da hinten rausfallen.
Ja, das bringt uns eigentlich so ein bisschen schon ans äh Ende der Sendung. Vielleicht noch was äh lustiges. Ähm.
Hinten dran ähm paar Sachen, die wir noch über den Weg gelaufen sind zur allgemeinen Erheiterung. Ähm was ist schon mal ein Kanada?
Nein.
Wie das da mit dem Alkohol läuft?
Staatliche Läden.
Mhm, genau. Du hast halt ähm also es ist nicht unbedingt ausschließlich so, aber ich glaube weitgehend ähm dass du eben so Alkohol in so staatlich lizenzierten Shops hast. Das heißt.
Also du brauchst eine Lizenz.
Brauchst du eine Lizenz und äh es werden halt viele von vom Staat selber auch betrieben. Und das ist übrigens auch derselbe Ort, wo es auch Cannabis gibt.
Und in Quebec.
Also in diesem französischsprachigen Teil von äh Kanada da haben sie dann irgendwie gesagt, so okay, alles klar. Also in unsere staatlichen Läden für Alkohol und für Cannabis so äh ja musste geimpft sein.
Ungeimpfte kommen wir nie rein. Woraufhin so die Impfquote mal so richtig spürbar nach oben gegangen ist.
Ja, immer gut, klar.
Ist so ein Vorteil, wenn man so ein System hat. Könnte man sich hier nicht jetzt vorstellen, hier ist man halt gewohnt, dass man irgendwie seinen Wirkstoff an jedem Speti äh kriegt und so und das ist natürlich äh für für für Deutschland äh
Land der Alkoholiker und Denker äh unvorstellbar, aber ähm interessanter Effekt, insbesondere dieser Cannabis äh Effekt, ne. Die haben aber noch ein paar andere ähm härtere Maßnahmen beschlossen, also
irgendwie ungeimpft bist, dann dann musst du irgendwie demnächst auch noch eine Gesundheitsabgabe
Zahlen und so, also so auch so was wird zumindest da diskutiert, weiß nicht ob's schon final beschlossen ist.
Irgendjemand hat dann auch noch herausgefunden, ähm dass äh.
Cannabinoide, also so Stoffe aus dem Hanf ähm wohl auch in der Lage ist es nur ein Labor jetzt, ne, nur so ein Labortest irgendwie. Ist die auch in der Lage sind, gegen Spike Protein zu äh binden, also weiß der Geier, vielleicht.
Hilft ja kiffen demnächst auch gegen Corona.
Na ja, das äh das diese Theorie oder Vermutung äh äh geisterte ja schon von Anfang an irgendwie oder sehr sehr früh sagen auch zum einen auch Tabak äh dass das generell irgendwie Rauchen äh und dann.
Ganz am Anfang.
Besondere ja, dass äh eben auch ja vielleicht mag das Virus dann äh diese Umgebungen nicht nicht so die dann so ja.
Ähm durchgeräuchert sind.
Also gibt's zumindest jetzt so Labortests, gibt's eine Studie, äh die das halt irgendwie einfach feststellt. Das heißt jetzt auch nicht, dass das wirklich äh in der in der in in der Realität, in irgendeiner Form umsetzbar ist, aber es wird halt alles mögliche ausprobiert.
Ne, jetzt gehen die langsam so die die die Themen aus. Jetzt geht das so ein bisschen in die Breite.
Ja und wer äh ansonsten noch irgendwie ähm.
Ansonsten noch darüber nachgedacht hat, ob irgendwie vielleicht eine Impfung nicht eine gute Idee ist. Es gibt irgendwie äh da so einen Mann, ich glaube, wo war denn das? Das war glaube ich in äh Großbritannien.
Wie der äh meint er hätte irgendwie covid äh gehabt und das hätte irgendwie schwere äh Zellschäden gebracht und das hat dann irgendwie,
ähm seinen Penis irgendwie um ein paar Zentimeter verkleinert und das geht wohl auch nicht mehr wieder weg.
So bin bisher noch einen guten Grund gebracht hat für eine Impfung vielleicht hilft das ja. Keine.
Ja. Denke, dabei können wir's dann äh belassen.
Ja, vielleicht doch noch eine Sache, weil ich auch dazu getwittert hatte, nämlich die Verkürzung des genesenen Status auf drei Monate.
Ah ja, hm.
Ähm so äh da kann man vielleicht nur zu sagen, also erstens ähm ja also.
Braucht man sich jetzt so sehr glaube ich nicht drüber aufzuregen, weil es ja erstmal vor allem Leute betrifft, die sich bisher überhaupt gar nicht haben impfen lassen. Ja.
So. Diese Verkürzung äh jetzt der.
Sag mal Karenzzeit oder Gültigkeit sage ich mal einer natürlich erworbenen Immunität auf drei Monate ähm,
so sehe ich nicht
medizinisch motiviert oder äh sondern dass es halt schon in erster Linie um,
zu verhindern, dass äh Leute, die sich bisher nicht haben impfen lassen, ähm dann den Weg äh
über die Ansteckungssuchen vermehrt, um sich irgendwie einen ja Immunitätsausweis zu verschaffen, um sozusagen dieses Loch zu stopfen, aber grundsätzlich sage ich mal,
Ähm nein, ich habe mir dann auch ein bisschen die Zahlen angeguckt, ja ähm es kann auch sein, äh dass ähm.
Man äh,
Nachdem man sich einmal infiziert hat, äh dass man sich reinfiziert natürlich mit einer neuen äh Variante. Aber grundsätzlich kann man erstmal davon ausgehen, wenn man.
Eine Covid-Infektion gut überstanden hat,
So auch wenn man sich reinfiziert, kann man davon ausgehen, dass die zweite Infektion äh in der Regel milder
verlaufen wird. Nicht in allen Fällen, aber wahrscheinlich äh das ist halt so, wie es grundsätzlich funktioniert, ja.
Mit der Immunität äh so ja. Beim ersten Mal äh ja äh nachm ersten Mal ähm ja das erste Mal ist das Schlimmste.
Ähm ja in so insofern geht jetzt von.
Infizierten und das zeigen dann auch die Zahlen auf den Stationen. Also es gibt.
Unter den Reinfizierten äh gibt es jetzt nicht viele schwere Verläufe. Sie reinfizierten sind nicht diejenigen, die jetzt die Intensivstationen oder die Krankenhausbetten äh grade belegen.
Ja ähm so das das kann man vielleicht auch auch einfach mal,
festhalten, aber umgekehrt, wie gesagt, man will es, man will halt politisch nicht,
also dieses Loch stopfen so und dabei kommen dann natürlich wieder jetzt Leute
äh unter die Räder äh dummerweise ja die eigentlich keinen Bock haben sich impfen zu lassen und die sich auch nicht impfen lassen müssten. Also wenn ich jetzt keine Ahnung als junger Mensch, junger, gesunder Mensch ohne irgendwie Vorerkrankungen
schon mal so eine Infektion durchgemacht hätte, ja äh dann.
Würde ich halt auch eigentlich eher zu tendieren ja äh nicht unbedingt einer Impfung hinterherlaufen zu müssen. So ja weil an sich grundsätzlich
so sollte das genügen ja ähm aber
äh natürlich nicht in anderen Fällen jetzt bei älteren Menschen oder so. Kann natürlich auch eine Reinfektion dann tödlich sein oder schwerer verlaufen, weil vielleicht dann die erste Infektion dann schon mal Schäden
äh Gesundheitsschäden gemacht hat oder der allgemeine Gesundheitszustand nicht so gut ist. Da ist dann jede Infektion und auch eine Reinfektion halt trotzdem eine eine Gefahr so. Aber nicht für.
Sagen normale Leute. Ja, für normale Leute ist eigentlich eine Reinfektion äh in der Regel äh ja ähm.
Nichts schlimmer, sondern sondern eben deutlich unproblematischer äh ja als als die Erstinfektion.
Milder heißt das Zauberwort.
Milder, ja, ja. Ja, milder, hm ja.
Ich.
Man weiß jetzt zumindest, was damit gemeint ist. So.
Kommt immer kommt immer drauf an, na ja.
Ja schwierige Debatte. Also ist natürlich ein bisschen äh ähm problematisch gelauncht worden in dem sie dann irgendwie gleich äh das Abgeordnetenhaus. Den Bundestag rausgenommen haben aus der Regelung so ein bisschen.
Ja ja, das war dann auch natürlich bisschen äh ja. Ähm und,
mein zur zur Impfpflicht äh vielleicht noch mal, ich meine, da äh schwankt meine Position ja auch immer wieder so ein so ein bisschen, beziehungsweise meine Position zur Impfpflicht ist, so
Jahr ab 50 dürfte eine Impfpflicht gerechtfertigt sein, ebenso für bestimmte Berufe
So für ja jüngere Leute oder man könnte vielleicht auch sagen ab 35 oder so also
aber tendenziell wahrscheinlich eher ab 50 wie das andere Länder teilweise auch gemacht haben. Ähm so äh wäre glaube ich das, was so.
Angemessen.
Äh ist unter Betrachtung der Gesamtsituation bei irgendein Alters-Cut muss ja auch machen äh so ist die eine Sache.
Und am Ende, was ich, was ich jetzt sehe, in der Debatte, ist, dass das Ganze jetzt seinen Lauf nehmen wird und äh ja, am Ende ähm.
Man dann keine Impfpflicht beschließen wird äh erstmal oder irgendwas was Halbgares. Ähm.
Meine das andere Problem ist halt natürlich im Moment auch noch mit der Impfpflicht, dass es gegen die grassierende Variante keine Impfung,
die eigentlich ja also sie erfüllt so eine,
so eine volle, dreifache Booster-Dosis erfüllt dann ähm für ein paar Wochen,
die Mindestanforderungen, die man eigentlich
an Impfstoffe stellt, die irgendwie schützen sollen. Da sind Grippeimpfstoffe oder so, sondern klassischer. Ja, also wenn man 60, 70 Prozent oder so Schutz ungefähr,
75 Prozent. Ja, aber das ist halt ja,
nicht. Ähm also es ist halt wie gesagt die also man könnte vielleicht sagen, dass die aktuelle mhm Impfung aktuelle covid Impfungen.
Gegen ähm.
Omikron ungefähr so gut oder so schlecht wirken wie klassische Grippeimpfstoffe gegen die jährlich auftretende Grippe. Ja und wir haben halt auch keine.
Ähm Impfpflicht gegen die jährlich auftretende Grippe, weil unter anderem eben die Impfstoffe ja so.
Wirksam sind, aber eben nicht,
wirklich zuverlässig schützen, so und wenn man dann wiederum guckt bei jungen Leuten oder jüngeren Leuten äh einfach äh sich anschaut, wie hoch das Risiko ist jetzt der Hospitalisierung oder der äh.
Oder zu versterben, dann ähm ja ist das im Vergleich eben zu anderen Risiken oder.
Anderen Infektionskrankheiten, die da grassieren, äh hat man dann auch ein Problem mit der Verhältnismäßigkeit.
Schwierige Debatte. Also ich denke, wenn man jetzt so sagt, ab fünfzig,
Dann seid ihr das halt auch gleich einfach gleich wieder an die Jüngeren das Signal so, ah ja so,
Ist ja nur für alte Leute und weißt du, dann hast du wieder diese Botschaft
mit drin, äh ist ja nicht so gefährlich für junge Leute und das
stimmt halt so auch nicht und es geht ja auch nicht dadrum jetzt den individuellen Schutz für den einzelnen herzustellen, sondern es geht um den kollektiven Ausbreitungsverbreitungsschutz so und,
potenziellen Überlastungsschutz also.
Ich will da jetzt auch gar nicht weiter äh drüber diskutieren. Das ist ähm schwierige Diskussion, aber ähm irgendeine Art von allgemeiner Impfpflicht,
muss es geben. Das ist zumindest so meine Sicht der Dinge.
Nur mhm ähm wie gesagt äh.
Aus meiner Sicht ab einem bestimmten Alter, wo man das jetzt hinlegt, muss man sehen, dass das.
Das kann man dann, das ist ein Zahlenspiel so, die Daten dafür hat man.
Ähm aber ich sehe halt ganz ganz viele Probleme im Detail. Äh auch, dass das Problem, was es mit Leuten, die es schon mal gehabt haben.
Was es mit den Varianten äh so gegen wie viel Varianten muss ich mich dann impfen lassen äh gegen die aktuell vorherrschende oder gegen die im Winter zu erwartende genau das ist ja dann dann immer auch so ein Ding also ich
Ich äh.
Die vom Frühwarnsystem vorausgesehen äh.
Genau, die von frühwarensystem ja genau. Nee, also ich ich äh sehe das,
alles äh gerade in in Deutschland schwierig. Ich weiß nicht
Vielleicht kriegen wir ja die Impfpflicht, also es ist man erklärte Absicht im Moment, aber ich,
würde eher sagen, die Chancen stehen 70:30, dass wir.
Sagt keine
allgemeine Impfpflicht äh kriegen und wenn wir eine kriegen, dann eben ab einem bestimmten Alter erst, weil ich glaube, dass das sonst äh wenn sie denn dann kommt wahrscheinlich das Bundesverfassungsgericht auch kassieren.
Äh wird am Ende des Tages, wenn man nicht höllisch aufpasst, zum Beispiel beim Alter, weil äh.
Ja in Österreich oder in anderen Ländern haben die das mit dem mit dem Alter nicht,
aus Spaß gemacht, ja, sondern da dem stehen halt einfach
Gründe äh entgegennehme ich äh weil es ist ja nur gerechtfertigt, denn alle zu impfen äh also auch die,
persönlich erstmal kein Vorteil davon haben ähm wenn es darum geht,
was wirklich eine Gefahr abzu,
Wenn an äh äh der Stelle und die Gefahr in dem Fall ist die Überlastung des Gesundheitssystems, ja die die allgemeine Gefahr. So.
Aber ähm
in der momentanen Situation äh so also von von Leuten unter 50 geht keine Gefahr für die äh äh Überlastung des Gesundheitssystems aus. Ja das Ganze schon mal so äh
einfach pauschal kann man das kann man das sagen ja ähm und äh die.
Also nicht, wenn Sie selbst krank werden.
Genau, nicht wenn sie
So, wenn sie's genau, also sie so also Leute unter 50 Drohnen nicht das Gesundheitssystem zu überlasten, wenn sie sich äh infizieren, so dass es dass es handelbar so. Das heißt ähm.
Ähm ja äh,
wie aber wie willst du dann dann rechtfertigen, sozusagen oder dann kannst du halt nur rechtfertigen äh das über den Schutz dann wiederum der Alten, dass die sich nicht anstecken können, aber wenn wir dann gleichzeitig sagen, oh mein Gott
ähm äh mit OmiCronch stecken sich jetzt sowieso alle an und die Impfung hilft nicht dagegen. Also im Moment ist es ist es einfach ein ein absolutes politisches Chaos und ich
äh beneide auch niemanden, der da jetzt irgendwie Ordnung
äh reinbringen soll und irgendwie das Ganze in einen Text gießen soll, der irgendwie Sinn macht. Äh epidemiologisch und äh für die,
einzelne Leute halt. Ja ähm.
Ja gut, wir werden das jetzt hier nicht abschließend äh besprechen, sondern ich denke, wir machen jetzt erst mal hier Schluss mit unserer Chronologie und ähm.
Hoffen euch Einblicke wieder haben geben zu können oder zumindest mal so einen zusammenfassenden äh Gedanken und wir haben ja auch die Hoffnung.
Diese Sinnreihe mal beenden zu können.
Oh ja.
Jetzt eigentlich auch mal ganz gut. Also wir sind wirklich der einzige Podcast in Deutschland, der aktiv an seiner Abschaffung arbeitet. Ja, also natürlich nicht UKW, aber halt irgendwie dieses Segment. So, das ähm,
Vielleicht sollten wir das mal um äh umbenennen. Corona-Quarterlie oder irgendwie so was, dann dann hat das schon mal,
Das ist so wie Brexit, da guckt man dann irgendwie alle drei Monate drauf, so ach ja, Corona.
Da eigentlich passiert und so. Da kommen wir dann bestimmt bald hin.
Ich bin auf jeden Fall zuversichtlich, dass wir dieses Jahr ein bisschen Spaß haben werden.
Und eigentlich mein gut.
Nach drei Jahren oder so spätestens äh wird's dann auch wirklich langweilig, ja. Und bei diesem Thema äh würde ich sagen, ich meine, es ist nicht, es ist nicht,
langweilig. Ich denke, diese diese Pandemie
es ist so eine wird wahrscheinlich so 'ne Generationserfahrung auch sein schon so ein so ein TV Einschnitt auch mit
ja mit mit verschiedenen Folgen man vielleicht sollten wir dann auf jeden Fall nochmal eine
äh Sendung dann noch mal machen zum Thema Pandemiefolgen langfristig haben wir zwar auch schon mal
in äh Sendungen vor ich weiß nicht, vor einem Jahr oder so äh äh glaube ich auch schon mal äh behandelt, aber das wäre natürlich auch
äh das Ding und.
Dann natürlich ist halt äh ja nach der Pandemie ist dann halt vor der Pandemie, das ist dann auch noch ein Thema und.
Das will jetzt bestimmt jeder hören, hm?
Ja auch schon die These, dass das jetzt so so die Warnschuss-Pandemie war, um.
Sagen, jetzt mal die ganze Welt so ein bisschen zu trainieren so bisschen Pandemie-Erfahrung äh ähm
und äh auf jeden Fall dann vielleicht auch unsere Fähigkeiten zu verbessern, möglicherweise schlimmere Pandemien auch zu bewältigen, wobei wir ja auch gesagt hatten
äh dass wenn's schlimmer gewesen wäre, man äh das Ganze auch äh früher gestoppt hätte das Ganze, ja.
So, dass es halt in so ein dummer Weise in so einen sweet Spot gefallen ist, äh wo ja ähm.
Ich merke schon, zum Ausklang kommt kommt wieder Dystopie Pavel äh hoch.
Mhm.
Sage ich schon wieder so lange an so einem positiven Arg gearbeitet so ja es geht jetzt irgendwie langsam.
Äh na ja.
Ende und dann könnten wir einen schönen Sommer haben und dann kommt Dystopie-Pabel und sagt so, ja.
Nach der Pandemie.
Das war alles nur eine Übung.
Genau.
Ja.
Es
Nix von hören.
Jetzt machen wir hier mal Ende. Leute, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, vielen Dank für eure Unterstützung dieses Podcast. Vielen Dank. Ähm ja, für eure Kommentare auch und all das wisst ihr sowieso, wisst ihr alles.
Ja und ähm ja wir horchen jetzt hier mal weiter, was was passiert und ähm wenn zu gegebener Zeit dann äh äh wieder,
dass bisher schon immer gesagt haben und zwar frühzeitig euer Frühwarnsystem Corona.
Ja, ja, bleibt gesund.
Tschüss.